it's crazy to think American Horror
Story is kicking off its 12th season
with delicate which honestly just
reminds me of the Taylor Swift song and
this season Stars Emma Roberts Cara
delvine and funny enough Kim Kardashian
it is the infamous FX Anthology series
with a revolving door of returning
actors and Fresh Faces created by Ryan
Murphy and Brad falchi if you didn't
already know that and would you believe
me if I told you that all 11 previous
seasons are some degree of fresh on the
Tomato Meter it's pretty remarkable and
it's true of course just how fresh each
season is is where we come in because
here are the top 10 American Horror
Story seasons ranked by Tomato Meter
right now on Rotten Tomatoes
countdown coming in at number 10
American Horror Story NYC taking place
in New York City in 1981 the 11th season
of the show focuses on a series of
murders targeting the the gay community
along with the new virus working its way
around town this one was anchored by a
couple of newcomers to the franchise and
Russell tovy and Joe manelo joining up
with returning stars like Billy Lord
Sandra burnhard Zachary Kinto and back
for the second time Patty LuPone y'all
which makes sense for the Broadway star
given the show's New York setting and
did I mention she's
amazing you're an angry man Gino and
your life is spinning out of control you
tell yourself this anger is caused by
the state of the world but you know it's
because you are dying everyone around
you is
dying I can smell it I can smell the
Decay sucking in everything and everyone
the New York season was the first out of
11 to not get an Emmy nomination but it
actually continued its run of being a
monster hit for FX and was nominated for
a glad media award for outse standing
limited or Anthology series moving on to
number nine cult now this season the
seventh one overall is actually set in a
fictional town in Michigan following
Donald Trump's election as president in
2016 where a cult is terrorizing the
people and when you hear the word cult
you're probably thinking you know drink
the Kool-Aid type of stuff and you my
friend would be oh so very
correct what is
that we need to do something radical
Jim Jones
said
oh death is not a fearful
thing it's the living that's cursed Colt
has one of the smallest Ensemble casts
in the show's run featuring AHS veterans
Sarah Paulson Evan Peters and Cheyenne
Jackson it also marked first appearances
for Billy ikner Allison pill and Lena
Dunham along with eventual regular Billy
Lord now emoms for the season included
the usual makeup and hair styling along
with an outstanding lead actress
nomination for Sarah Paulson now at 73%
Fresh the consensus from Critics on this
one is that it quote intrigues with
timely over-the-top creepiness and lots
of clowns I'm officially adding
over-the-top creepiness to my vocabulary
number eight American Horror Story
double featured now this one consists of
two different stories each making up
half of what is the 10th season the
first story called red TI focuses on a
family that moves to an isolated Beach
town in Massachusetts and starts to meet
the town's mysterious true residents now
the second part Death Valley follows a
group of camping students that get
caught up in a conspiracy involving
extraterrestrials and various presidents
of the 50s and 60s I mean this just
sounds so fun that includes Neil MCD as
Dwight D Eisenhower and Sarah palson as
mamy Eisenhower well a version of her
anyway dear you are not thinking
straight no I'm I'm the only one who is
thinking
straight I don't even know who you are
anymore allow us to Enlighten
you yeah I don't think it totally
follows true events along with Paulson
who is one of a handful to appear in
both parts the cast in the season includ
friends like Evan Peters Lily Rabe
Leslie grman and newcomer to the
franchise moli culen now this was the
season most affected by coid so it was a
bit delayed but good horror comes to
those who wait and this was another hit
for FX and with critics number seven
American Horror Story murder house ah
yes the season that started it all s in
2011 this one follows a family that
moves from Boston to La for a fresh
start but they moved into a Haunted
Mansion which is never a good idea um
honestly I get it though I mean the
housing market in La is rough get the
lights what is going on what is going
on the parents are played by Dylan mcder
and Connie Brittain and the daughter by
taesa Fara Britain would reprise the
role later for the apocalypse season
marking her only appearances on the show
also in the cast is American Horror
Story vet Jessica Lang as the creepy
neighbor a role that would earn her an
Emmy sag and Golden Globe Award the
season itself was nominated for 17 emys
overall and it brought in the best
ratings FX had ever seen for a series
premiere on its way to being one of the
top two cable series of that year number
six American Horror Story Rowan Oak and
number number six also happens to be
season 6 which I got to say is kind of
eerie it was set from 2014 to 2016 and
it follows the supernatural events that
occur in a renovated farmhouse in North
Carolina now unfortunately it sits on
the land where the Rowan Oak Colony
mysteriously disappeared from in the
1580s so the general sights and sound on
a farm like pigs for instance aren't
really quite the
same
dude yikes the first part of the season
is presented as a paranormal documentary
reenacting the experiences of a couple
who lived in the house the second half
is more found footage style portraying
the documentary's doomed sequel Rowan
Oak's cast was epic led by Cathy bats
and Sarah Paulson along with people like
Cuba Gooding Jr Wes Bentley Angela
Basset and Lady Gaga plus other familiar
faces the critic's consensus for what is
the first certified fresh season on this
list gives love for its break from prior
Seasons formats and its return to the
quote spookier smaller scale of the
series's first seasons can you believe
that we've horror storyed our way
through half of this list already just
to recap it was NYC at number 10 Colt at
number nine double feature at number
eight number seven was murder house and
Rowan Oak meeting in the middle at
number six at least it wasn't a triple
six situation
now I'm sure you're wondering what are
numbers 5 through one going to be and
there's only one way to find out well
actually there's a couple ways but
you're already here so let's do it
number five American Horror Story freak
Show now this season is set in 1952 and
it tells the story of one of the last
remaining freak shows in the United
States and their struggle which is real
making their appearance more difficult
in the town of Jupiter Florida is a
handful of dark entities lurking
including a killer clown known as twisty
and I just got a let you know if you
don't like clowns now is probably the
time to look
[Music]
away for me oh
okay thank you I mean Florida clowns are
the worst just kidding I can say that
cuz I'm from there now John Carol Lynch
is a man behind the clown while the
freaks include conjoined twins played by
V Sarah pson a bearded lady played by
Kathy Bates and a three breasted woman
played by Angela Basset I mean that is
the American Horror Story try fact up
all that adds up to 20 Emmy nominations
the most for any American Horror Story
season and while trophies are nice the
best way to remember this season is by
the cover songs that were actually
released along with it including Jessica
Lang singing Bowie's Life on Mars Sarah
palson doing Fiona apples criminal and
Evan Peters doing Come As You Are by
Nirvana I mean can you just imagine the
cast karaoke nights number four American
Horror Story apocalypse this one came
eight seasons in and it's actually a
crossover between the murder house coven
and hotel Seasons it's set in the near
future and it's about the Antichrist
played by Cody Fern who brings on the
apocalypse through nuclear warfare up
until I'd seen the season I thought the
Antichrist was my old building manager I
mean I told you guys housing in La Is
Not Great anyways the crossover meant
the of a bunch of past characters
including the witches Council from coven
with Sarah Paulson plus Angela Basset as
Marie Lavo the voodoo queen I mean
coven's my favorite but I'll wait until
we get there to tell you that CIA promis
Papa
LBA the darkest and most corrupt Voodoo
Queen soul for mine you serve him well
in my place you're a fool Marie
laal you would have done no different if
you were
Queen Sarah palson actually made her
directorial debut for episode 6 of
Apocalypse along with playing multiple
characters I mean is there anything she
can't do the show was moved from the
limited series categories to straight up
drama at the Emmys for this season with
Jessica G Lang picking up a nomination
for outstanding guest actress the
critics consensus for this season says
that Ryan Murphy and his Murderers Row
of witchy performers literally saved the
world and franchise number three
American Horror Story asylum this season
is set in 1964 and centers around the
patients and staff at a church-owned
Massachusetts Mental Asylum founded to
treat the criminally insane it features
Sarah Paulson Evan Peters and Jessica
Lang Leading The Way with names like
Chloe 7y Zachary Kinto Jenna danan and
Maroon Five frontman Adam Lavine in
supporting roles and speaking of Jessica
her singing The Name Game song was
actually released as a single and it is
because it is so unreal
[Music]
The Name Game Judy Judy
Judy now arriving as the second season
Asylum was facing some serious
expectations after the show had become a
hit and it honestly didn't disappoint
we're talking 17 Emmy nominations more
than any other show that year including
outstanding miniseries or movie with
James Cromwell winning for outstanding
supporting actor number two American
Horror Story coven and as you may have
already heard this one's my favorite now
this season is set in 2013 and it
follows the ever shrinking group of
witch descendants who survived the Salem
witch trials in the 1600s as they fight
for survival I seriously can't get
enough witchy content the cast earned
five Noms for acting including Angela
Basset for supporting actress and
Jessica Lang for lead actress which she
actually happened to win and for good
reason so have you owned this place
long what are you you think I think when
they say good black don't crack they're
not wrong what your secret what's yours
your manic your cost more than my rent
Woman Like You wipes her ass with
diamonds she don't just end up walking
in here for hair extensions my
my aren't you perceptive you know
exactly who I am and what I'm capable of
just like I know exactly what you are
which I can smell the stink of it on you
the season centers around in all girls
boarding School in New Orleans for those
who carry the witch Bloodline with
flashbacks Landing in 1692 along with
the 1830s 1910s the 60s 7s and '90s I
mean talk about some serious period
pieces with 17 Emmy nominations in total
Kathy Bates also took one home and the
critic's consensus is that this 85%
certified fresh season is a potently
structured Fright Fest number one
American Horror Story 1984 set in you
guessed it 1984 this season takes place
at a remote newly reopened summer camp
after a massacre happened there 14 years
prior the ensemble cast is led by Emma
Roberts and includes John Carol Lynch
once again playing a derang murderer but
this time on the loose from a local
insane asylum it was heavily influenced
by classic slasher films from the 70s
and ' 80s like Halloween and Friday the
13th and it totally gives off those
vibes chill just clean it up like you
always do no you can't kill every single
person that wanders through here yes yes
I can SC there are no rules for the dead
you don't know that you don't know why
we're stuck here no one does Ray but you
know what I realized nothing we do
matters despite being the first season
to not feature regulars Sarah Paulson
and Evan Peters this ninth installment
still managed to be a mega success along
with one of the highest audience scores
for the series it's 88% certified fresh
Tomato Meter score is good enough for
the top spot on this list with critics
calling it quote a bloody good time I
mean there is nothing like horror set in
the80s well my friends that is our list
I mean who knew that just a handful of
actors could play so many freaky
characters for more on this series and
more like it be sure to hit up rotten
tomatoes.com thank you for checking out
today's lists until next time I'm your
host Nas Perez and we'll see you back
here for more Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]
countdown
n